so I got some good news this week I won  the Washington DC Society of  Professional Journalists award for the  best weekly columnist write the Congo  appears on Mondays in the hill thehill  calm and I want to thank my editors now  Standish Bob Cusack as well as the  publisher Jimmy Finkelstein there's been  a lot of criticism of journalism in the  news lately fake news enemy the American  people but we're lucky to live in a  country where honest journalism and  different opinions are available to us  all and that's the basis of an informed  American people and we are the basis of  this great Republic so hats off to the  First Amendment ACLU watch yourself Greg